on Prime crime
annual holiday tradition becomes a day
of Terror
oh my God but the drama and twists of
the case
[Music]
don't end in the interrogation room I
need to take a break this man right now
is having a stare down with me it's very
disrespectful he pounded his fist
frankly it makes me scared
thank you
[Music]
hi there everybody I'm Jesse Weber and
welcome to prime prime this is where we
break down the most high profile and
memorable True Crime cases what starts
out with a horrible crime that destroyed
the lives of so many people turns into a
trial that is still hard to believe
[Music]
November 21st 2021 Waukesha Wisconsin
crowds gathered along Main Street for
the town's annual Christmas parade two
of my children have been extremely
involved in the dance team they have
dance in the parade for quite some time
it was always a really happy fun event
which should have been a Fest of time
with family and loved ones suddenly
becomes a nightmare caught on camera
I remember hearing stuff like I don't
really know some commotion behind me
[Music]
oh my God oh my God
it was one of those where I can still
feel the wind from his vehicle as he
passed me a red Ford SUV unexpectedly
comes barreling down the parade route
striking multiple people
oh my God
this is a a Christmas parade that
happened I think it's almost 60 years
that it's been going on and then
suddenly we have an individual that and
just destroying every memory anyone's
ever going to have of that event
oh my God oh my God
oh my God nothing like this has ever
happened uh to this extent in Waukesha
County you can't believe it's your own
Community you can't believe it's your
own friends and family
[Applause]
[Music]
these are quickly alerted and begin to
respond to the chaotic scene
there was someone running through the
parade route
in total six people are killed dozens
injured and hundreds of lives changed
forever I followed the vehicle and I saw
everything that happened I kind of stood
there in shock for a little bit
and then from there on it kind of hit me
like I need to go find my daughter when
I found her
she was in front of the vehicle and once
we got to the fourth floor ICU it was
there that they told me that they had to
intubate her because of the seriousness
of her injuries
I got it oh authorities immediately try
to figure out who did this but the
driver of the red SUV disappears
however shortly after he's captured on
camera running through yards in the
surrounding neighborhood so what do we
think we
we think he's fleeing the scene
up on a ring doorbell camera at a nearby
house
hey can I I caught some I called an Uber
and I'm supposed to be waiting for it
over here but I don't know when it's
coming can you call it quickly please
I'm homeless police eventually tracked
the man down
[Applause]
this matches the description of the guy
that got called on who was going door to
door over here what is your name
did I do something
is Darrell Brooks though the driver
after he's detained authorities begin to
question him including the FBI yeah
for real
you know that he during his adult life
moved around to several different states
and had collected criminal histories in
all of those places along the way I
don't know what's going on I just know
that you know you're down in this
neighborhood someone called
you know you didn't know what you were
doing down there and things like that
they're not obligated to tell
um a suspect everything they're not
obligated to tell them the truth about
everything it doesn't seem like people
are being honest with me now
at this point that's why I'm like why
should I talk to you if you're not going
to be honest with me this is just the
start of Brooks's interrogation when we
return things get very tense for the
love of God you know what happened
yesterday for the people tell me what
happened
will work with the car
[Music]
it's sad that an event that is supposed
to be happy and joyous
just turned into something so horrific
in a matter of just minutes
[Applause]
in November 2021 tragedy strikes the
small town of Waukesha Wisconsin when a
rogue SUV barrels down the route of an
annual Christmas parade leaving six dead
and dozens injured
[Applause]
while police located the abandoned red
Ford SUV they eventually apprehend the
suspected driver Darrell Brooks cameras
captured him going from yard to yard and
even trying to seek Refuge at a
stranger's home while his behavior is
suspicious is he the killer
they weren't fully honest with him they
didn't tell him exactly what the
investigation was in fact they told him
this was more about the domestic
violence incident I just want to know
what is going on I'm going to tell you
investigators start by asking Brooks
about an incident with his on-again
off-again girlfriend Erica Patterson an
incident that occurred right before he
allegedly drove the car into the parade
I'm being charged with anything
well she's making some like I said
alleged allegations against you kind of
you know for being physical
where are you here why Erica was here in
Waukesha in the first place it was an
attempt to get away from Mr Brooks after
he had run her over with that same SUV
in Milwaukee just a few weeks earlier
how did you come to meet with her in
Waukesha I was supposed to be getting
some money from her
how did the conversation with your end
with me walking off and her being pissed
off that I didn't want to hang out with
her harassed her the way that he did
to force her into the vehicle just to
punch her in the face a picture of
America Patterson that black eye just
shows just a fraction of what she's been
through although Brooks denies attacking
Patterson detectives press and search
for a possible connection between the
altercation and the parade attack if she
ever make you lose she ever would cause
you to lose control
there's no question he's in a rage and
we see it in the video when he's with
his ex-girlfriend and then and
investigators questioned Brooks further
on details of his account how did you
get out here
what color is it black tan have any car
you can drive at all I do have license
but no no vehicle you didn't walk the
walking shop whose car did you guys use
my friend I'm just trying to figure out
how you got here
yeah I know but it seemed like you're
trying to like
like gave me up or something in the
whole
story that he concocted about getting a
ride out here from a friend that was all
just intended to mislead
I just have concerns if I fact check
that Darrell's not telling me the truth
you did not come out here in a tank here
okay
we've got a key
in your pocket
I think what was interesting is they
were both playing mind games with each
other he knew this was not about a
domestic violence incident and neither
of them are completely truthful with
each other okay what's going on man
some people said you were driving kind
of crazy
we got reports of it I know you know
what car I'm talking about they were
persistent uh they were fair and at the
very end they confronted him with video
and photographic evidence
[Music]
who else would it be
pay you no that's not me
that's not you that's not me
that's not you no I don't know
you say it like that
Brooks would end up being charged with
76 criminal counts including six counts
of first degree intentional homicide but
this is just the beginning the trial of
Darrell Brooks Jr is something no one
will soon forget furthermore today I'm
not because that's a lie
no since he want to make a record and
not be accurate so let's be accurate on
the record since you think you know so
much
foreign
lie to me man you have lied to us as
well almost a year after a red SUV
barreled down a parade route in Waukesha
Wisconsin killing six people and
injuring dozens of others the alleged
driver of that vehicle is on trial
Darrell Brooks Jr faced 76 criminal
counts including intentional homicide
charges this was an accident and he
mistakenly wandered onto the parade
route after passing all this all he had
to do was stop they could have paused
the parade didn't
it was intentional this trial though was
anything but conventional do you wish to
represent yourself in this case
yes I do there are times when an
individual chooses to represent himself
and it ignores to his benefit there are
times when jurors can actually feel
sorry for the defendant this isn't it
was not planned this incident was not
intentional a lot of suffering involved
in this incident a lot a lot of
misunderstanding
this trial was unlike any other trial
any of us have ever been involved in
because of his self-representation I
would like to represent myself to
represent myself as a sovereign citizen
throughout the trial Darrell Brooks
would bring up many things that were
irrelevant one of them was that he was a
sovereign citizen it basically was that
he's not a citizen of the United States
and therefore the government the judge
the law doesn't have any control over
him we all kind of figured he was going
to go
The Sovereign citizen Direction there it
was just one of those where we're going
oh great here we go it's going to be a
rodeo are we going to address subject
matter jurisdiction
the written decision that I previously
entered is what I will stand on I don't
think he actually really believes that
he's a sovereign citizen I don't think
he believed that there was an issue of
subject matter jurisdiction I think he's
smarter than that his motive was just to
be a disturbance objection
it's overruled now you may answer great
questions
it was
distracting with all of his
interruptions and ramblings would you
describe them all as being about teenage
years
overworldly my answer
do you even know the state of Wisconsin
grounds grounds
he would on the flip of a switch without
without notice just go off on irrelevant
uh topics and not let it go the defense
would like to call the plaintiff state
of Wisconsin to the same
objects the objection is noted it is
sustained call your next witness please
reason for the sustain not relevant I
believe the jury deserves to know who
the plaintiff is Mr Brooks please move
on but Brooks's outbursts would become
even more volatile I'm a grown man with
grown kids don't nobody ain't nobody
gonna talk to me like that nobody he
reminded me of a two-year-old every time
something started to go not his way he
would throw a temper tantrum literally
this court ordered Mr Brooks be removed
from the courtroom due to repeated
interruptions he took his shirt off as
well I'm also told that he is
threatening to throw and break items and
Judge Jennifer Darrow would find herself
on the receiving end of much of Brooks's
blow-ups I don't care what you believe
fully all right it's not a game the
amount of lashing out and disrespects
was beyond belief Mr Brooks
you're a public service I respect your
courtroom I respect you you're a public
servant though your job is to be the
referee you know I didn't think that he
would be that disrespectful he has no
respect for humankind at all I would
like to provide the defendants and the
court
West
so that had to be that had to be said
that index
that's not how it was set up that was
how I think you want to run the record
back I need to take a break this man
right now is having a stare down with me
it's a very disrespectful he pounded his
fist frankly it makes me scared but she
has to listen to that and respond to it
so her temperament was she deserves High
Praise for that coming up we break down
the legal Arguments for each side and
before the final decision the families
don't hold anything back I can only hope
they lock you away someplace so deep the
rat's chewing your fingers at night
thank you
[Music]
Mr Brooks's statements that the audio
doesn't work when I mute him is simply
false
in 2022 a jury in Waukesha Wisconsin is
listening to the trial of Darrell Brooks
Jr the man accused of driving an SUV
through a holiday parade the year prior
a trial where the defendant decided to
represent himself in Wild fashion you
are not being respectful to this
proceeding or to this jury
Brooks faced 76 criminal charges for
allegedly killing six people and
injuring dozens of others he wanted to
write by these victims and by our
communities these families all suffered
so greatly that we absolutely wanted to
do our best
I watched the body fly up onto the hood
and her head snap back
and the body remained on the hood as it
passed the side of my vehicle asking
these witnesses to relive these events
was very difficult for us did you see
the red SUV strike any people in the
Catholic community group several
it was in the air
like bowling pins some of the witnesses
had indicated that they even noticed
that he almost had this look on his face
like he knew exactly what he was doing
exactly where he was going he saw a man
focused on the group ahead of him
is that Daryl Brooks that you saw yes
while the prosecution would present
evidence tying Brooks to the crimes
Brooks presented another side of the
story well what were the defenses to
this case the first was that there was a
mechanical error with the car you
believe that there may have been some
mechanical problems how were you able to
come to that determination
that was my initial concern because of
the noise that the engine was making the
second issue was that they didn't have
the right guy
could you see anybody inside the vehicle
your answer was I could not see the
person real clearly and then the last
one he brought was the person who did
this did not intend to kill the
individuals because they honked
beforehand so
you heard a horn beeping
yes was it coming from
the vehicle that you tried to stop I
believe that it was and at one point
Brooks appeal to the jury's emotions and
even improperly argued that the jury
could ignore the law you have the power
to nullify any law that you don't agree
with
objection moved to strike in a statement
sustained in late October 2022 a
12-person jury reached a unanimous
verdict after about three hours of
deliberations we the jury 5 find the
defendant Daryl e Brooks guilty of
first-degree intentional homicide
hey you are to be removed right now the
jury found Darrell Brooks Jr guilty of
all 76 criminal charges we had witnesses
that identified him we had video that
identified him the fact that he was
close by the lies he told he darn well
knew exactly what he had done nearly a
year to the day following the attack at
the sentencing hearing Brooks faced the
victim's families and the survivors of
the parade attack Massacre and there's
there's nothing this court can do that
would provide Justice in my eyes so all
I ask is that you brought and you
brought slow times where I felt Justice
wouldn't be served until he had to take
that SUV to his chest exactly the same
way he treated my child and I hope the
look on my daughter's face before you
ran her over haunts you for the rest of
your life that whole experience really
opens up your eyes to know how fast
things can be ripped away from you and
can change your life in a matter of
seconds jessalyn is doing amazing it's
surprising how well she has bounced back
the recovery process has been
a very long journey
very long and exhausting it was a lot of
physical therapy and doctor's
appointments I'm doing pretty good as
for Brooks he had some words before his
official sentencing not only am I sorry
for what happened
I'm sorry that you could not see
what's truly in my heart but judge
Darrow wasn't convinced frankly Mr
Brooks No One Is Safe from you
this community can only be safe if you
are behind bars for the rest of your
life
this court is imposing a life sentence
without the possibility or eligibility
for extended supervision
consecutive to one another
and our thoughts just stay with our
community and our families
they still need a lot of love a lot of
support and a lot of prayers closure is
a word that gets used a lot in this
business but I hope at least they can
rest knowing that Daryl Brooks is
sleeping in prison every night
it's really not an understatement to say
just how absolutely devastating this
case has been for so many and yes a lot
of attention focused upon Darrell Brooks
and his wild behavior during trial but
we shouldn't forget what this case has
always been about and that is the
victims because despite all of Brooks's
arguments this jury seemingly didn't
believe anything he had to say and they
delivered a verdict that holds him fully
accountable for what he did
that's all we have for you here on Prime
crime as always thank you for joining us
and until next time stay safe
[Music]
foreign